good morning mission my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help some of your journey today's
message is don't sleepwalk through life
over to you 45 I advise students as much
as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job I mean you know
don't sleep walk through life and don't
don't say it's all going to be great you
know I'll do this and I'll do that and
you know I'm just marking time to be
older that I've told people that's like
saving up sex for your old age I mean it
just is not a system it is it is not a
good idea yeah what are you urging them
to do I'll explain here's what I'm
talking about I it it just yeah
you really want to be doing what you
love doing and you can't necessarily
find it on your first job right but
don't give up before you find it one of
the best questions you can ask yourself
period is if I had all the money in the
world what would I do ask you something
if you had all the money in the world
what would you do because when you
answer that question it tells you what
you should actually be doing right now
we'll see people have no idea
most people don't know what they would
be doing and as a result people
sleepwalk to life they're just trying to
make their that mortgage payment or
their red paper just kind of scripted by
constantly survival mode sleepwalking is
actually built in cultivating I had a
good comedian with somebody who's on my
team part-time and I was asking her okay
I asked that question if you had all the
money the more good you do and she's
talking about
in bringing their parents to Canada
buying a house and all these things to
cook a great sets are the same care
right you traveled you saw the places
you want to seen you know you brought
your parents over you bought a house buy
your whole family's ever great all
that's done and you still have money are
you going to do and that's the problem
that's the work that you should be doing
exact the work that as you start doing
it's going to be able to give you the
money to afford all of these things that
you want to see with your life but as
long as you're working for somebody else
not chasing your dreams not sure which
one is you not having a plan and just
sleepwalking there's no financial things
that you have in mind I'm never going to
come true we're always going to be in
survival mode and so the good question
of extras does the least one Supporter
if you had all the money in the world
what would you do with it because our
first instance is all the money things
mostly we feel that we're missing like
education like the car like the house
like the bills all that stuff but you
still have money left over what would
you be doing with your life and if you
get a really solid answer that you're
never going to really have a great plan
for when you're going eating a lot of it
in your business if I had all the money
in the world I've been helping
entrepreneur I've been doing what I'm
doing I would still make youtube videos
you know I designed my life in such a
way that I haven't hasn't made a
decision based off of money for a very
very long time I don't think I'm a great
deal that I don't want to work with I
don't make youtube videos only trying to
make money right I don't do anything eat
my last in my business is just trying to
take a cash-strapped and I think it's
important I think it's important that
when you need to have interesting and
said this is the work that he would be
doing regardless of you thought if you
got a paycheck for it or not if you look
at every single successful
or what drives that what motivates them
it's never money money is important but
it's never the number one and so it's
strong encourage you to ask yourself at
least once a quarter if you had all the
money in the world what would you be
doing in your day-to-day life and then
go out find a way to start doing that
right now
does it have to be some big pipe dream
does it have to be only when you win the
lottery or when you sell your business
right now fine it's always they get
started right now because it's possible
nothing stop stand walking through life
so the question today today is our
questions right now
can all of mine in the world what would
you be doing with it
leave it down in the comments below
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Antonio
Centeno some real men real style Antonio
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book you want word and post it
into your Twitter accounts I really
appreciate this part raised enough so
glad you enjoy to read so thank you guys
for watching I believe in you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again smart more day for another
shot of espresso
[Music]
person you are that you know kind of
points to the things you're good at are
you 12 you're not going to know are you
get 16 you're not going to know if
you're 18 maybe if you have a special
talent yeah right you know you can throw
a baseball 100 miles an hour you can
sing and your voice is incredible you
know you're you know a concert pianist
you're a chess grandmaster if you have a
specific skill set or talent that just
immediately propels you to top yeah you
want to follow that yeah but I remember
having a list I still have it when I
graduated from college I was getting
ready to graduate and all of the
different industries that I thought I
might want to partake in when you find
something you're good at
yeah go for it I was never really into
technology when I was a kid but then as
I got a job that used it I found out I
was good at it and once I found out I
was good at it then it became a lot more
fun yeah you know when you're good at
something it's almost always fun yeah
yeah and once it was fun and I combined
that with you know my business skills
then I thought okay I know how to make
money at this stuff I know how to sell
now I know tech that gives me something
I love to do and so you know what I owe
I tell people the key is find something
you love to do and be great at it if
you're passionate and you're successful
you'll wake them you'll wake up one day
rich you won't really be going for the
cash it's happened to you everybody I
talked to it said success doesn't
remember the day they became a
millionaire no idea not important to
them they remember winning they remember
building a business of being successful
again the pursuit of freedom manifests
itself in passion that's really what
it's about do not make any decisions
based on money none it's the worst way
to make a decision which I know is so
hard to say I mean I didn't grow up with
any money and I know so many of us are
our families have a lot of stake it put
a lot into us made a lot of sacrifices
for us and you say you don't have the
luxury of doing that but I actually
think you do you will be more successful
if you make decisions based upon what is
going to feed your soul make you feel
value valued validated you know have you
waking up in the more
wasting to work whatever it might be and
I can tell you after a short amount of
time money will not be enough at the end
of the day a bigger paycheck is another
suit or more real estate more square
footage that's what it comes down to you
end up with another room and a fuller
closet and after a while that's not
going to do it